foreign
what else do you think open source might
be able to solve and I've had some
reasonably direct experience with
watching I suppose one example of what
you described which is automatic and
very good friend Matt mullenwig I'm an
advisor to automatic and for those who
don't know Matt who's been on the show
multiple times was a lead developer of
Wordpress very familiar with open source
and then has built
a sort of services and Enterprise grade
secure stable solution for for many
different businesses and people in the
form of automatic
so I'm deeply interested in this and I
know you are as well you're a big fan of
Open Source what else do you think open
source could be applied to
or might be applied to first of all I
think people are relatively familiar
with the big individual software
projects Linux being yeah the most
well-known it's over 20 years old now
it's clearly the most
use the operating system in the world
and
what people might not know about it is
a lot of scientists believe it's the
most secure and that's kind of
counterintuitive oh all the codes public
how could it be the most secure but it
gets beat up the most you know because
it's used the most
there's a great piece of writing an
incredible piece of writing
called the cathedral and the bazaar that
was the first kind of Magnum Opus on why
this open source thing might work and
another thing people don't get is
the cathedral in the bazaar compared are
you trying to build up like the Gowdy
church or or a Bazaar which is super
flat and wide and
obviously built by lots of people and
the thing is like open source is way
better complex problems than simple
problems and it's a very complex
problems that would be hard for a single
company to do and so if you're building
an operating system it might have all
kinds of edges on how it integrates with
other systems you know different drivers
you might need and
the world is is able to build that
whereas an individual company would be
very difficult
and so we started to see that in MySQL
and there have been others like mongodb
and wearing one called elastic and like
there's been a lot of successful
companies around single software
Frameworks
something started happening about 10 to
15 years ago which is people started
using open source in more complex ways
and sometimes using it defensively
rather than offensively so the most
well-known is probably Android right so
Apple had come out with this Smartphone
you could only get it on ATT it scared
the out of everybody not just
Google but it scared the out of all
the other telcos that scared the
out of all the other handset
manufacturers and so Google did this
clever thing they said oh we're going to
create a competitor but it's going to be
open source so you can trust us now
there's different versions of how open
something is and and Android is not very
open but at the time compared to the
threat of Apple it seemed like a much
better trade and so they got the world
behind them on this thing and it took
off since then that model's been been
repeated in in some esoteric ways
there's Facebook has something called
the open compute project and if you want
your Hardware to go into the
Facebook data server room it has to be
compatible with their open source
framework and what that means is
no one can
have an IP claim against Facebook
because you basically sworn off your IP
so they're commoditizing the stuff
they're going to purchase since then ATT
and China mobile have worked with the
Linux Foundation to do the same thing
for the wireless and Wireline equipment
stack so they're defining Open Standards
for their next-gen products and if
you're a supplier that wants to sell to
them you have to agree to those
standards and once again you're you're
out of the IP game so they don't get
held up it's very clever stuff would you
mind expanding on that a little bit the
ipps well let's go to the Facebook one
because it's more understandable it's
called the open compute Foundation it's
it's managed by the Linux Foundation
acts as a steward much in the way that
the crypto world
thanks a dow manages this loose
Federation the Linux Foundation does
that Linux has been a dow for 25 years
it's super interesting and so that group
helps
they're like a non-profit
overseer of the project break ties yep
they do patent defense which I think is
super interesting so they pull patents
in no one sues within the open source
project but if someone were to come
attack it you know you'd go out after
him so anyway Facebook has all these
equipment in their data center
networking equipment storage equipment
computers software so right so they just
created this thing called the open
compute Foundation that defines Open
Standards for how all these products
work and so if you want to be on their
purchasing list you say yes we are
compatible with this open standard and
it once again it basically commoditizes
that equipment so it just gives Facebook
more leverage with a broader spectrum of
suppliers every one of these things has
a website and you can go see and so now
you know Amazon and Google they're all
part of open compute right if I'm
understanding you correctly tell me if
I'm missing something they're trying to
create conditions such that they
wouldn't end up back in the day when I
moved to Silicon Valley I worked in
storage area networking and EMC at the
time was pretty famous for kind of being
a black box like if anything broke if
anything went wrong like you need a DMC
to fix it or upgrade it and so to avoid
being held hostage or losing leverage
with suppliers
Facebook made this move is that a fair
description absolutely and then another
high profile one that's genius I mean
it's very smart oh it's super clever
Google was very afraid of Amazon running
away with the cloud services business in
AWS and so they had a piece of
technology called kubernetes and this
was right around when Docker and
containerization took off and kubernetes
was an orchestration layer for
containers and Google decided what a
bizarre name what was it kubernetes
sounds like an Italian pasta yeah well
here's the thing though they decided
that it was in their best interest to
take this technology and gift it to an
open source Consortium they got the
Linux Foundation to to manage it and
they went out and recruited IBM and HP
and all these other vendors to say oh
yeah we'll support kubernetes because
everyone wanted to make sure that people
weren't locked into Amazon and
eventually it got so successful that
Amazon had to announce support for
kubernetes and now if you need to move a
workload from Google to Amazon there's a
common framework for which to do that
and so you're less locked in
so this seems like it's become at least
based on the examples you gave I gave a
very refined reliable counter punch that
Google uses I call it defensive
corporate strategy yeah yeah and I'll
give you two more very recently well
there's always been open street maps and
that's kind of interesting because it's
data rather than you know but the open
street maps team was very kind of
non-commercial so they didn't like when
Apple and these and Google's obviously
running away with the maps business so
if you just look this up like within the
past four weeks there's a new open
source map group that's going to live on
top of open street maps it has Facebook
and Microsoft and you know the other
parties that don't want Google to run
away with it and quite frankly I think
that's pretty cool if you talk to
actually someone you should have on it I
think that would be really cool is Jim
zimlin who's run the Linux foundation
for this whole time oh because good idea
he's a huge believer and this kind of
ties into Matt Ridley's ideas having sex
that not having IP is actually great for
the world right because it just creates
constraints for people being able to
take advantage of things and so you know
mapping's super interesting to me
because it's data oriented there's
something called risk 5 which is an open
source processor believe it or not that
has a lot of momentum now you'll see
people on the earnings calls for arm
they'll start is this a competitor is
this going to be a problem because it's
completely free license you know and
China is a big backer of Open Source and
you could understand why because the
West is accusing of of Ip theft so this
is a world where yeah you can't be
accused it's a safe space yes it's crazy
but I wonder what's possible I'll give
you some kind of grander ideas first of
all I think autonomous vehicles should
definitely be open source I think
everyone benefits safety's higher
communication layers are better like the
idea that you would use artificial
intelligence to figure out whether a
light is red yellow or green is really
stupid because it's a state
machine it is in one of those three
states and that could be communicated
into the software like you you don't
need to infer that that's a known thing
but you need a Common Language your test
Suites could all be used by everyone
Academia could be working on the same
thing that the corporations are safety's
higher easier for government to get
involved if it's a single standard
and I wonder about other things like the
NIH gives out 40 billion dollars a year
and many of these projects end up as you
know research that leads to a drug that
leads to having a 17-year patent life
and gets sold at 300 Grand a year or
whatever like why wouldn't we say if you
take NIH dollars your research is open
source why do we use government dollars
to fund stuff that becomes proprietary
that doesn't make any sense to me yeah
this is something that you and I can
have a conversation about separately
yeah this is I look at the state of
nuclear energy where the costs are high
because of Regulation not because of the
actual product and I wonder what if the
globe had a standard for fission-based
nuclear reactor like wouldn't we get to
lower price points wouldn't we get to
safer products wouldn't they get more
involved it seems possible to me